lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or a licensed professional
[Music]
hello
[Music]
welcome to lifeline episode you know i
don't know what episode it is but i i
tell you this look what i got the mirror
now oh
they're coming back to be on sale soon
yeah
you know it is on sale that don't push
me oh
calm um
too many drinks uh but
also what that one's yours which one's
mine that one yeah it is yeah also let's
uh this one's mine we're starting the
show but this one let's get this out of
the way first and this one's mine
sometimes i forget but i'm gonna be in
dallas grand prairie texas that's
crystalline on tour go to chrisleya.com
for here grand prairie texas which is a
dallas play wichita kansas atlanta
georgia washington d.c
stockton september 23rd oakland
september 24th
i'm going to be doing uh
illinois
october 7th and 8th
uh raleigh october 21st
savannah georgia october 22nd
denver colorado i'll be there november
5th at the bellco theater cheyenne
wyoming november 6th boston
massachusetts
two shows early and late at the wing
theater november 12th lakeland florida
that's a new one that just went on sale
december 2nd and jacksonville florida
december 3rd and crystallia.com for
tickets go get them good seats uh the
dallas one is coming up
soon so all right great
thanks for listening all right great you
should do your whole thing like that
like you're an emo guy like what like
how it was over your eyes
the whole show but i mean don't actually
do it but anyway okay i mean i'll do it
i'll do anything do you have do you have
uh
gray in your hair yet or no my beard but
no
uh no i don't think so i might have i
think i might have found one i was
reading a book the other day and i
turned the page and i felt like a
[ __ ] piece of gray hair i was like is
this mine or is this the last person who
read this book
there's a length of my hair though the
good thing about that is now you can
just use it as a bookmark i did
um
and uh so yeah i have now like four or
five or six gray hairs in my head
i don't think i've ever seen one i
really got him in the hand yeah you
gotta you gotta be close you gotta be me
really to notice you know yeah i have
more in my beard i bet you well you than
me yeah no yeah than you not not in my
opinion of course in my hair dude i want
it to be i wish that happened at the
same time yeah i mean hair is [ __ ]
cool dude gray hair is cool but also
it's i don't feel like it's cool just on
the face no it's not i mean hair yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
uh so i got to get that going maybe i'll
just dye it i'll throw some [ __ ] uh
you know what i mean just for men silver
yeah or just get like a streak like a
skunk maybe get like a [ __ ] well that
could be cool because then it would look
like it's really like a thing you have i
i went through something bad right like
right crash test dummies music video
remember that [ __ ] oh did they say that
well i know the song
it's all different no it's not all the
same
[Laughter]
wow [ __ ]
if somebody left like that in a movie
would be the best acting of all time he
goes
[Music]
wow that's something
that was this ball
slowed down wouldn't go to change what
the [ __ ] i [ __ ] it up i crossed it no
he goes once there was his kid
who got into an accident and couldn't go
to school
he finally came
back
his
hair
had turned from black into bright white
that's it yeah dude how did i remember
that i was transmitting it from my brain
that's amazing you can't take credit for
that but see now it it
me saying it about the white hair
triggered it for you
and it's because of me that you got it
right okay but well i don't know i do
uh bro bride
that sound kind of rock that was i love
these 90s right yeah so is their [ __ ]
hair right
dummy there's nothing more 90s than
really long
really completely dead straight straight
as an arrow heavy hair dark hair
heavy hair like a curtain like a [ __ ]
like a curtain like a blackout curtain
you would see on a really long window
yeah like a heavy like to move your like
literally here you gotta go
right yeah you could hurt your neck
like a heavy backpack yeah and then you
go you garden and then you say what
happened they say i got into an accident
um
yes
you know who else had that what extreme
remember that ben yep what was their big
song uh uh it goes like this
we're so extreme
what's the name of that song the extreme
song the famous extreme song yeah we
don't do we don't know i don't know well
now i need to [ __ ] figure it out so i
don't know about the ideas where the
[ __ ] huh where they're not just [ __ ]
only because we were in the 90s
yes but not only because so how do you
feel about the 80s though
whatever this oh so you feel more about
the 90s this year oh oh it was more than
words remember oh yeah dude
and i'm good though
yeah
i hated the [ __ ]
i loved it dude the video was so sick
they had the long hair without the pony
they're the one guy had the pony and the
other guy they were brothers like me and
you and they had really long
curtain sheet curtain [ __ ] dark dark
hair dude
yeah they would fall over yeah
oh
more than one
on the ground with his hair like i can't
get up i can't get up to
heavy
wow
um remember when you pushed nick
shooper's backpack yup because it looked
like it was too heavy it took so long
for me to fall down
he [ __ ] fell over he was trying so
hard to stay up and i just go dunk
because his backpack was so big dude
this kid's backpack it was so mean that
you did that
he needs to learn bro
that was so mean no the best part was he
was trying to get up on a curb and
that's what did it yeah that's what he
was absolutely did
by the curb and then fell bro we laughed
for [ __ ] time i was looking at his
face and you know like when you watch
shark attacks there's no
expression in their face there's no
change the scariest thing about shark
attack is that it doesn't feel anything
about it yeah that was nick schubert's
face unbelievable dude that's what a
great [ __ ] i wish i thought of that i'm
gonna steal that okay um wow dude just
being a shark falling down yeah just
being a [ __ ] this is what happens to
me with a backpack this big boom yeah
that's what it was yeah well so what
about the 90s and then what about the
80s because i was born in 1980 you were
born in 1983 four three three i know
that and uh 1983 and then so you
probably remember the 90s more i
remember both the 80s in the 90s i
remember just obviously the end of the
80s uh but the 90s were like the
thing for me that's like wow it's weird
that like when i think about my life
most of my memories are condensed into a
very brief window from like
12 around 12 to like 15. like so much of
my memory is is is concentrated around
that period of my life
and i guess because i was so formed
right around then yeah and that would
have been the mid 90s yeah
dude i
was watching
childhood videos the other day
i can't watch them
i hate you like that but why can't you i
i don't know it's like i was [ __ ]
locked in a room and [ __ ] i just i
can't watch them it makes me feel sad
dude that's what i've always said and
you've always been like why
that's how i feel i feel that way always
i don't know what i don't know what it
is but like i just it makes i maybe it's
i see myself being young and youthful
and happy and then i and now it's like
there's so much other things in the
world i think it just makes us whether
we realize it or not think about dying
maybe maybe especially because you see
so many people on the video they're like
oh they're dead they're right there
yeah because you killed them yeah yeah
it's just it's just weird and it's like
you gotta there's always the old person
with their [ __ ] like glasses [ __ ]
pocket thing in the pocket yeah just
like it's like a thing anymore yeah and
it just makes you realize that time
moves and everything changes and yes
it's
yeah it's too much we can't process too
much feeling and emotions i can't i
can't i can't feel all that man yeah
yeah it hurts yeah i always say i don't
even like pictures
i don't like pictures of me young around
my house who's me young was she chinese
or yes yeah i don't like pictures of me
young i don't know
no but really i don't like even looking
at me at a younger age wow yeah it's
deeper yeah definitely yeah no that's
fine but it's deeper but i had such a
good job it doesn't make sense like in
that sense but uh it's true
don't like it don't want to do it you
can't make me
i wonder if we were repressing anything
that like [ __ ] would like if like
russians came in and just was like
[ __ ] up
russians went real far russia threw us
around but no russians came in
when we were that age around eight
threw us around and [ __ ] okay well
and
so far no i remember their names were
vladimir of course i would kind of bet
you were going to say that and the other
one was
uh vladimir
with an o not an is that an actual
reformation yeah vladimir and vladimir
is that actual those are two russian
names i think so right right right right
vlodimir and they [ __ ] us that's i
want to say that's so confusing but but
there is jon and jen so yeah john and
john just no h anyway they [ __ ] us
the worst high five yeah
toyota for all of us listening we high
five the back end but food
i love what you do for me remember when
the guy would [ __ ] jump on me like
this so [ __ ] dude i wanted to sell
after that plummeting dude he goes like
this toyota yes boom freeze
i love what you do for me toyota dude
the most bitch-ass [ __ ] bro was that and
that was 90s was that did you know what
i love doing i for hours on end i can
sit there and watch and this is what
youtube's great for youtube yeah [ __ ] oh
dude all of you if anybody has anything
negative to say about youtube youtube
is the greatest thing that ever happened
the internet in general obviously
good sides and bad sides but youtube and
also wikipedia not only can you [ __ ]
learn anything wikipedia that ever
existed that you want to know about but
you can also watch anything that has
ever been [ __ ] recorded on video or
[ __ ] film
lawyer out of work so
it's the best [ __ ] thing anyway i
watched 90s commercials yeah i know it's
good and a loop on a loop they're so bad
they're like hey guys talking to m m's
and [ __ ] and the m m's are like you know
what are you doing no just eating cereal
right the noob yeah
right so angry about it you know but
damn dude
i'll shoot them all but okay well that
what i like about dimitri and democracy
uh vladimir and florida sorry uh
but what is what is weird is that i like
thinking about
how times have changed when i'm outside
of thinking about like when i watch
commercials
i like wow times have changed so much
yeah when i'm in the mix get it get me
out of here yeah yeah i wonder what
happened to us when we were younger
deeper
so let's uh get into the show huh okay
we're going on with the advices yeah
hi chris hi matt my name is melanie i
live in portland oregon
and the question i have for you guys is
in 2018 i started my own business uh
which is a daycare center cool history
already
um and 2020 was projected to be my best
year
obviously covet hit yeah i'm super proud
now that it's 2022 we've made it on the
other side and i'm doing really well
there's so many things i should be proud
of but i'm finding that this sense of
entitlement that people have across all
industries
in any sort of social exchanges i've
observed
is one where people are just
blatantly rude and and have a sense of
entitlement of how they how they should
be able to interact with each other i
feel like we forgot how to socialize how
to talk like normal individuals
uh it's really affecting my
view on going to work i don't love what
i do anymore
and
uh it is my own business and free conch
so i like
do literal and verbal spin moves on the
rag
um and i can't retire at 32. so you'd
like any advice on how to survive
postpandy entitlement thanks
well i think first of all it's
just as the pandemic came it's gonna go
and eventually
people will
re-regain or retain their ability to be
in social situations and not be total
[ __ ] either weirdos or [ __ ]
everyone went through a period where
they were so [ __ ] uptight and
confused that is not a good mix and
we're still all kind of coming out of
that and everybody's [ __ ] edgy and
everybody's weird and and scared kind of
and i i think the
the solution here is
uh or or my advice here is that it's
gonna pass so just [ __ ] wait it out
and find the people that you can make
fun of and talk to your friends about
them i guess that's a good i guess that
uh
though is it gonna get better in past do
you think because like
it i know you say the world keeps
getting better and better i don't say
that well you say well i mean
yeah you do no no i in a in a really
really really broad sense yeah say that
like in a steven pinker way yeah yeah
yeah okay well who's that but yeah so
but like if there's like uh
in the dave flowey poop way yeah but
it's like wow
in a in a [ __ ] john charisma [ __ ]
well i'll be the sickest thing ever john
charisma dude
imagine being named john charisma hello
everything's going to get better yes um
with one of those [ __ ] what are those
[ __ ]
what's the callers that go up and down
oh wow those white ones update more and
so you know what i'm talking about i do
yeah charisma
[Laughter]
wow
no you know what that is like a [ __ ]
porn star that like thinks he's better
than all the other porn stars just
doesn't want to do like john rod or
something yeah yeah yeah like [ __ ]
yeah yeah johnny comes a lot huh [ __ ]
that dude i'm john charisma johnny comes
a lot you know so uh
anyway we talking everyone named john
what we say about how things get better
you don't think they are democracy comes
a lot um
yeah no it just seems like things are
going into the [ __ ] and i know every
generation has always said that they've
always said that yes like they've every
generation has always been like it's
getting worse it's getting worse i mean
like [ __ ] you know they've probably
seen it back in [ __ ] roman times and
[ __ ] definitely everyone has always said
that yeah like they're not even feeding
people to the lions anymore where's this
country headed right
and uh
and so um wow thought of the worst joke
didn't say it and so um
so yeah so but you're right about now is
a unique it is it's like a blip in the
everything's getting better all the time
thing because things have stagnated
crime rates have gone up right violent
crime rates have gone up i got you it's
like education is way [ __ ] up right
now there's [ __ ] inflation the
economy's [ __ ] up but it's all because
of kovac but in a jimmy pinkerton way
it's a lot better right steve
pinker okay okay so
the thing is
uh john charisma i think that
i i don't i don't i mean look i struggle
with this honestly i i i stand up comedy
was my favorite thing in the world
and the pandemic happened
uh
i i obviously could break also because i
was [ __ ] canceled and [ __ ] but like i
stopped doing stand-up and then when i
went back i didn't like it the same and
it took a while for me to get back
to where i liked it again and what about
now and now it's
it's i you know i like it a lot but
there are some nights that i'm just i'm
not feeling it you know and that never
used to happen and i don't even i don't
even want to admit that to myself and
here's why i'm able to admit that to
myself and be honest about that is
because i had my son and my son is more
important than anything my family you
know my family the the three of us more
important than anything and so
so
having that
and um
i can i can be honest and be like it's
okay to have nights where i don't want
to go do my job
um
and sometimes i find it on stage and i'm
like [ __ ] this is amazing and sometimes
i don't like the other night i was like
[ __ ] i had two shows at the improv
and i just [ __ ] with the crowds were
i was like ah i didn't do so well and
then i left and then i saw another i saw
ian edwards you know yeah next the next
thing he was like man i wanted to quick
stand up after that show i was like oh
[ __ ] you had a rough set two [ __ ] yeah
it wasn't me you know yeah so um but
yeah i don't know man look this is just
part of the times it's not always it's
not always going to be like this people
about her thing though specifically i'm
saying it's not always going to be like
that i know but i know but on the heels
of that people
are
really uptight about all things around
kids and watching kids anything school
related
also people forgot how to socialize in
every [ __ ] area of life people are
like had they forgotten how to be around
each other yeah and i do think that that
is something that absolutely people are
going to
rebound from and people [ __ ] suck
before too don't get me wrong but
they're going to go back to the normal
way of sucking this new way of sucking
is going to slowly dissipate and go away
there is a uh yeah the masks also are
cra it's just everything is just crazy i
saw somebody [ __ ] uh the other day
at a place with a mask on inside
drinking something with a straw and she
would go like this
while she was eating yeah yeah it was
crazy so she would chew with the mask on
yeah where what was inside good side
where
a cafe making it up
no a cafe that's [ __ ] legitimately
weird yeah weird okay well that's so
that's that's the point though in two
years she won't be doing i know she
won't yeah right
yeah okay so what about though right now
like she wants to know what she can do
before things get better right right but
cherry pick the stories about the real
big [ __ ] find humor in it and go
talk [ __ ] about those people to your
friends and make them laugh make it a
hobby of your [ __ ] talking as a hobby
because the business you started is
[ __ ] sick you love it it's what you
want to do find the little things that
are so bad it almost reaches a level of
absurdity also there's more that matters
right now than your business you
understand and to you and and i think
that that's what we're you're figuring
out is that oh my business is
uh i loved it why don't i love it as
much anymore and it's because of all of
the other [ __ ] going on yeah so dude
once that [ __ ] changes you'll get back
on track and in the meantime dude
you know do some [ __ ] you know
get on tick tock oh wow do a cooking
video wow for real though people there's
that chick that started jumping rope on
instagram and all she started in the
beginning of the pandemic now she's like
a professional jump roper she has
millions of followers and she's just
like jumping throwing the [ __ ] back and
forth that's your advice to her you know
start drawing
i think find the real absurdity in it
absurdity in it
find it funny and then go talk [ __ ]
mad [ __ ] about those people behind their
back i don't know if that's good but
maybe in a comedic way it's okay okay
yeah no it's good
oh boy
you want to read it yeah i'll read it
because i didn't you read it because
it's hot as [ __ ] okay and i don't want
to be reading it because it's hot oh go
ahead hey matt hey chris hope
everything's going great with you guys
thanks for everything that you do huge
fan of your work especially matt oh cool
i'm a i'm a 37 years old man that's bad
bad grammar been married for nine years
and my wife and i are expecting our
first child
now my wife has a couple of male friends
that she talks to on the phone almost on
a daily basis quote male header in
parentheses male heterosexual friends
okay end parentheses and to be honest
i'm okay with that
i get that it's healthy for our friends
to talk to and i trust her completely so
this really isn't an issue
i on the other hand another
parenthetical and here comes the advice
part and parenthetical do not have any
female friends all of my friends are
male so i wonder sometimes if i should
reach out to old female friends i used
to have see how they're doing or is this
[ __ ] because in the end i'll just
end up wanting to [ __ ] them that guy
puts asterisks like we don't say [ __ ]
and [ __ ] all the time so just wondering
what you think of this situation but
also in general when it comes to married
man having female friends versus married
woman having male friends thanks again
and i apologize for any spelling and or
grammar errors i might have
purified safari
he wrote safari uh
yeah i
i um
i don't think it's a big deal if he's
saying his wife has a couple male
friends that she talks on the phone
almost daily a daily basis
do you he says oh he's okay with that
i get it something for her to have
friends to talk to and i trust
completely so this really is an issue so
why so the want to keep in touch with
other f he doesn't have female friends
he just wants to he just wants to [ __ ]
other people i think honestly really and
be around them yeah i'm just like if
you're really okay with it then like
that's the end there's no advice
you don't seek out non-friends
to become friends with them that's not
how like
they're if they're your friend already
then great yeah become friends with them
then great but you don't like
is this like retaliatory like what the
[ __ ] is it it seems like it's
retaliatory but the thing about it is
bad but the thing of course that's bad
but the thing about it is
making new friends of the opposite sex
is definitely a little bit more
dicey than
may than an old butt like are these the
dude friends that he has
that she has yeah if she's had them yeah
before him yeah then [ __ ] it you know
what i mean of course you know yeah like
i mean
who cares yeah anything i i i this is
just crazy
this is just so much
i don't know if you want to [ __ ] people
other people but like on the other hand
here comes the advice part do not have
any female friends all of my friends are
male so i wonder sometimes if i should
reach out to old female friends i used
to have and see here's the thing that's
so weird if you're really okay with it
you wouldn't have that next thought i
think he's not okay he's not okay with
it okay we figured that out yes he knows
he should be okay with it and he's right
about that but he's not just acknowledge
that you're not okay with that and then
ask yourself why because you really
shouldn't be with it doesn't [ __ ]
matter dude it doesn't matter you said
you say yourself you [ __ ] trust her
go to her right now and be like baby
you've got a lot of male friends i'm
insecure about it that's what my advice
is is everything cool and also do you
think maybe you could back off with that
or are you going to be like no those are
my friends and then i got to deal with
it because maybe she'll be like huh yeah
i guess i do talk to them quite a bit
maybe i should open up to you more
yes dude maybe dr phil eat your heart
out but
she shouldn't even like regardless of
him she shouldn't become less good of
friends with these friends of hers just
because he's insecure yes what they
should work on is trying to make him
less insecure yes and that mostly comes
from him yes again not trying to get new
chicks to
god is just what the [ __ ] or old exes
old flags hey what's up my girlfriend's
on the phone with one of her guy friends
what you doing wanna hang yeah hello
well
work's been good
i don't want to [ __ ] you
i i swear i don't want to [ __ ] you
because it's this i'm doing the same
thing that my wife's doing and she
doesn't want to [ __ ] them so anyway lol
all good lol you still work it [ __ ]
i know it's been three years
yeah dude come on yeah go bro get
together
here's the red flag here
my my uh my wife has a couple of male
friends that she talks to on the phone
almost on a daily basis male 1 how to
succeed and to be honest i'm okay with
that yeah that's why i said i know
insecure that is the most
shaper
yeah dude i read that and in my mind i
would just use it so i had to stop
reading it
okay i mean getting [ __ ]
i mean everyone would read that go oh
yeah
all right cool
next one
hey chris and matt i don't love the show
love what you guys are doing
uh seeking a little bit of help in the
situation that i'm in first ad for a so
i was dating this girl
and i broke up with her because
she basically started dating this other
dude that's a good reason okay well
actually and uh
about two months after i broke up with
her her new boyfriend posted a tick tock
and tagged me in it
and
basically was saying thanks for screwing
things up oh and like
i don't know it was just really mean
yeah and uh i'm wondering how you think
i should respond
i haven't really done anything about it
um so
yeah
keep on uh
keep on rocking in the free world
the [ __ ] that's so funny unbelievable
dude you know that's um that's tom hardy
always
doing an action always the best thing in
a situation like this
um i i fully believe this always is to
pretend like you never saw it yeah yeah
i agree always i agree because it's in
the past it doesn't even matter this
guy's a [ __ ]
loser that's so
[ __ ] that that guy did that yeah dude
dude do not do anything
it happened already and now by the way
that chick is dating that dude good
because
they can be with each other bro that is
so whack yes do nothing it was so dope
when chris rock did nothing after will
smith correct yes he still did nothing
yes dude that's so
excellent [ __ ] you want to be ill as
[ __ ] yeah feel this [ __ ] dude i mean he
had the [ __ ] lighting set up in that
video yeah and then the [ __ ] like
obviously as a photographer you know
yeah he knows and just chilling with the
black socks on he was the lavmike he was
cool he was good uh do nothing act like
he never saw it if it ever comes up in
your life act like you never saw it play
dumb play [ __ ] yes like totally
ignorant of anything it never happened
yeah never bothered you and if somebody
tells you about it it still wouldn't
bother you because who the [ __ ]
gives a [ __ ]
okay well where's therapist but honestly
i would be such the [ __ ] way he was
swiveling in the chair was sincere and
that's okay but dude that is
unbelievable that guy did that but hey
congrats you know what that's great
because you know why now you know that
you have another enemy so put that in
your pocket right put that under your
towel and figure it out it's good that
you haven't done anything yet and you
waited to ask us because emphatically i
feel this way do not do anything in fact
until the day you [ __ ] die pretend it
never happened just honestly don't do
anything and
uh you
you should try to block that guy out of
your mind even right like dude i don't
even know that that guy that guy oh
what's his name again okay cool we won't
be able to do it but try try every day
don't wake up try every day i don't know
about you on that that's great but do it
don't try just do it yeah just he
doesn't exist oh hey dude
he's gone um where's hypnotist oh hey
dude
he's gone most chilling ass hypnotist
most chilling ass hypnotist hey oh hey
dude
so when i snap my fingers he will
forever be gone
you listening dude
okay
hey when i snap my fingers you're gonna
be so
much the chilliness ass dude yeah and
huh
that's good man that's a good question
and a great question i feel very
strongly about this yeah me too it never
happened it didn't happen it never
happened and
where's hypnotist okay cool let's do it
all right
what's going on matt and quest love the
show lifeline it's really cool that
you're helping out the common folk out
here wow uh my question for you guys is
how do you keep up with your
organization and productivity i'm
feeling like i'm having
cuda tendencies
and i don't know how to really deal with
those i i it's hard to stay focused with
me you know for myself getting focused
um i recorded this video like six times
uh but anyway
any advice would be great advice i work
overnights at a warehouse 6 p.m to 6 a.m
maybe that affects things maybe i have
adhd or something else
i don't know
thanks for being cool and awesome
wow he's cute that guy's cute he is cute
also where did you get that mascot so
why do you have that mask why are you
wearing it now i have five of guitars
yeah you know what he uh well he's
running out to disguise who he is first
of all your your job the six to six
thing p.m to am is definitely affecting
oh dude all of it it's a hundred percent
you need to [ __ ] experience sunlight
you can't be sleeping during the day and
then not yeah that [ __ ] you up yeah you
basically become whatever mask you're
putting on yeah exactly but also dude
you obviously shred yeah he obviously
said he's got five guitars at least and
that's all we saw so he could have had
more is he is that slipknot that was
slipknot i mean basically it's not his
[ __ ] mask and also this guitars but
um
yeah uh
huh he's asking how to get more
organized or how to first focus don't
spend
any time being hard on yourself for not
being focused and and organized yeah
organized i got to get organized um
don't spend any time like beating
yourself up about that
either be be in one of two states at all
times either doing something about it or
not doing anything about it when you're
not doing anything about it just be
chilling and enjoying yourself like what
john linden said oh my god but the thing
about how like
wasted time is not what any time you
enjoy wasting is not wasted time got it
okay we're done with it yeah we got okay
um
but when you are
advice on how to get organized is hard
because i don't know what you do or what
you want to do
but he's organized with his guitars yeah
i don't know if i believe this guy
completely i think that what he what it
is is he has a lack of doing the things
he doesn't want to do he has a lack of
desire to do things he doesn't want to
do and that's where the organization
[ __ ] thing comes into play yes
figured it out and i think i can relate
to that right i know 100 i want to do
like four things how many do you want to
do yeah less yeah okay there we go so
it's not a combination two things right
i want to do one thing but like i want
to do half of a thing but so i've never
done anything so but this that's what
this guy is because this guy i i see and
i'm like i'm looking at this and i'm
like am i sherlock holmes do you know
what i mean like because because i i see
it and i know the answer but why do i
know the answer right because i'm doing
all this stuff subconsciously like
focusing on the lint on this thing all
he took it to the dry cleaners
oh the [ __ ] you know what i mean oh
i know what you mean bunched up but what
do you mean
real quick and i get it okay and i don't
even know why but now i get it because i
did a sherlock holmes thing where i'm
like dude you're not organized really
yeah that's very interesting well then
why do you have six guitars placed in a
[ __ ] neat fashion like that equal
distance same height
i don't buy it either and also you have
that mask on it was ready wasn't it you
thought about this so it's not about
organization it's about you don't want
to do the things that you don't want to
do yeah yes i identify with that and i'm
like sherlock holmes is stop saying that
part though
i'm like that was like sherlock holmes
that wasn't anything like sherlock
holmes there's nobody dead nothing's
stolen you sure that comes real
uh no
so nobody's like sherlock holmes yeah
including you yes no but i think yes i
think that i think that guy needs to i
would suggest and hear me dude [ __ ]
you know what i mean okay fourth down
and i'm
[ __ ] and i see the guy and i'm like
this is what we got to go for we're down
because i'm just gonna go for the hail
mary okay i think you need a whole
[ __ ] life
change what they call it the circadian
rhythm like you're not getting it yeah
yeah you're not getting it dude you
gotta you gotta wake up in the day do
the day sleep at night
and and
maybe there's another shift he can do
i mean you know he asked for it already
yeah maybe maybe maybe not
okay yeah if there's another possible
shift ask for that but uh do uber eats
if you're asking what the reason is that
you're disorganized i keep doing it
because i made this stupid [ __ ] joke
disorganized and sort of all over the
place can't get your [ __ ] together so to
speak i think uh your job has so much to
do with it
um so just know that and be a little
easier on yourself about it but uh i
think as chris said even though i don't
like how he studies sherlock holmes he's
probably right in that you're talking
about the things in life that none of us
actually want to do
so just [ __ ] do them because you're a
[ __ ] adult yeah also uh
yeah no that's that's right i do agree
with that i agree with myself okay yeah
so let's do it let's see the next one my
baby
all right guys here's the dilemma make
this quick
start talking this girl when i lived in
california from back in washington we
facetimed every night got close one day
she stops talking to me a little bit
time goes by i find out she's having an
affair with one of my friends dads wow
and i was like whoa it got messy ready
got sloppy i get back home she got a fat
ass so
she hit me up one day and i was like i
still want to hit it
she comes over i hit it
then she starts talking about dating and
i was like nah and then she freaks out
on me tells me i'm a [ __ ] boy tells me
she regrets having sex
she says i gave you my body
[ __ ] i gave you my dick it's not like
this is a game and i won right we both
wanted to have sex here yeah
i don't see what the [ __ ] happened i
don't see what you thought
you know what i'm saying you know what
i'm saying
what you guys did [ __ ] hey oh no okay
that that and the part kind of
yeah yeah yeah little off track but um
[ __ ] yo he's at the end he's just
like [ __ ] big up some of ku klux klan
yeah uh though
also dude
there's one thing you just gotta reply
with she's like hey
uh
i gave you my body and you just say
he gave my friend's dad your body too
sayonara i mean
you're out dude there's no [ __ ] way i
mean there's no way i ain't going to my
friend's dad
she had sex with your friend's dad while
they were was it while they were dating
who cares oh no that's a big [ __ ]
difference not even a little bit you
[ __ ] his friend's dad
i guess yeah that's insane dude it's
pretty cool you're dating somebody and
then she [ __ ] mr marquand
insane dude yeah no that's insane in
[ __ ] insane small town [ __ ] dude
you're wearing a bolo tie i'm sherlock
holmes so i get you're in a small town
because i'm picking up all the [ __ ]
different things oh boy man i [ __ ]
your ex-girlfriend me and a boy okay
that's mr marquan talking yeah but um uh
no but yeah
what is the advice the advice he just
wanted to tell us a little story
but the advice is ow
do you gotta get rid of that girl she's
she's true he shouldn't have
she's trump
hit it again no i love when i was like
she got a fat ass like in the middle
just this guy you know i didn't know if
that was a good thing or a bad thing you
meant it as a good thing right
yeah yeah okay yeah yeah yeah yeah um
okay but so you i i need to get one in
your words hit it again and she i mean
that's not that weird as i hit it you
know i'm just making sure that everyone
knows these are not my words okay yeah
i'm not saying it's out of control
weirdness
[ __ ] that's not my word but
no but he uh what the [ __ ] is he even
seeking here he wants us to be like well
he he at the end he was like right
[ __ ] oh
yeah bro [ __ ] but we're you know i
get it dude you both did your thing it's
fine it's all good and she said i gave
you my body and you say you [ __ ] my
dad's friend
he didn't say that he said that he
should say that i know i know i know you
say you [ __ ] my friend's dad gotta go
sayonara and jump in the [ __ ] pool
what was she
she was mad at him for what reason again
that she didn't want to because he
didn't want to date her oh okay you [ __ ]
my friend's dad dude just say did he
want to date you like did my friend's
dad
well i don't yeah i don't wanna the
thing is i know that you're dating
around and i know that you also you're
dating around maybe seeing my friend's
dad so that might not be the greatest
thing because i have to see my friend's
dad a lot yeah
he's 60.
yeah but i mean you i don't think you
should have sex with this person or
anything no no you gotta you gotta let
god this is that's it for her yeah yeah
i also anyone that says like i gave you
my body it's like
okay but it's sex like why are you
putting it that way that's a that's a
red flag like that's a i understand what
sex is it sounds like i gave you my body
just wants
him back even from the gym she's acting
out yeah maybe she wanted him back even
when she [ __ ] his friend's dad his
friend's dad yeah
because the friend wasn't going to do it
you know the friend wasn't going to do
it the friend's too good of a friend but
the friend's dad is just like oh this is
just one yeah that's where i come in
the friend's like can i [ __ ] your friend
no what about hey hey can i have your
dad's number it doesn't i'm way ahead of
you maybe i didn't have a huge boner
maybe he didn't even know
i'm way ahead of you i'm completely
erect
and you have a fat ass how shitty is
this guy's dad oh the the what's up with
the dad it's just the dad needs to get
call in here and ask how to be a better
[ __ ] dude
grows up and [ __ ] uh no i don't know
i don't want to imagine that i'm just
saying dude
it's not good but i know no no [ __ ] it's
not good and i'm just like
that's where i come in with a [ __ ]
raging boner yeah no kyle's 25 and [ __ ]
yeah and he's he's like dad and i go
son
it would be his friend too that's so
weird did you see that ass though son
son it's fat now how fat was the ass
damn that's weird [ __ ] am i right you
putting it that way makes it sound even
weirder it's so [ __ ] weird everyone's
weird in this situation yeah and you're
the least weird well know that you're
[ __ ] weird yeah yeah yeah he's weird
but uh you know looking like a [ __ ]
mormon sect with that bolo tie he had on
yeah
all right all right another one that was
a good one was it i like it hey chris
my question today is about my family uh
my mom and my stepdad have been together
for 15 years or so
[Music]
i love them both but i've noticed
something between them lately uh my mom
is the kind of person who
she gets really defensive about you
calling her out she can't accept that
she's wrong about anything and lately
i've noticed her being kind of
mean and irritable and snappy towards my
stepdad and he just kind of takes it
yeah you know he's the kind of person
he's been struggling with anxiety a
little bit a little bit of depression
uh and i feel bad because i can just see
her being mean to him sometimes when i'm
over there he doesn't say anything about
it so i wonder if you think
i should confront my mom about it or not
uh
maybe your advice would be helpful
thanks
bring it up he seems like a nice guy
first he's got the wrong voice for who
he is yeah but i think i i actually
should sound more like this maybe he
should bring it up with the stepdad
do you want me to oh i thought he was
insinuating that the step that does have
a problem with it oh it's i mean it
sounds to me like maybe he's oblivious
to it
but you might be right i'm just saying
but no even if he is aware of it say you
know i noticed that my mom is like kind
of saying these cutting things to you
i just want to before i say anything to
her i just want to like see you how you
feel about that if it's like
you guys talk about it sometimes or like
i don't want to butt in but like i've
started to notice it and and i feel like
saying something sometimes i just want
to know where you're at with this
you know what i'm saying or you could
just approach you'll be like
say your beta huh and you like and you
like that and you're cool with it okay
because my mom she's walking all over
you because he's a deal he specifically
searches
gets defensive and she's getting
defensive right every time you bring
something up she's like what the heck's
your beta
so what are we going to do about that
are you going to say something alright
all
right
you could do that because somebody's
going to say something because we can't
let this pitch into getting out of
control okay
if he's if he's saying this about his
own mom and then moon walk out then that
means something to me because that's
blood and his stepdad is
ostensibly someone he met later in life
this is his
actual mom so like there must be some
[ __ ] shitty stuff that she's saying
yep
um but i i don't i would recommend not
really getting
involved with the more volatile one
that's why i say maybe i know but that's
his blood though that's the thing it's
like saying it to the the dad the
stepdad saying i mean it's been 15 years
though so that is a long time okay i
missed that so so maybe you say like yo
i've noticed mom being defensive what do
you feel about that it's not just
defensive though in the in lieu of or
after the defensive [ __ ] yeah she gets
increasingly over the course of days and
weeks
gets shitty more cutting and shitty yeah
so so then say i've noticed she's been
doing this have you i you don't want to
go behind your mom's back but you have
known him for 15 years he's been in your
life yeah so it'd be like how do you
feel about that and she's just like i
don't know it's okay to be like oh so
you're better are you
interesting okay well that's something
and then you talk to the mom and you'll
be like oh it makes me uncomfortable
when you're [ __ ] cutting down
my [ __ ] stepdad well if you're going
to say something i'm already pissed off
with you because you gave me the wrong
voice for my body that's the thing you
say to your mom right make it about you
not like you're sticking up for the guy
yeah you make it about you like that
makes me uncomfortable right when you
say mean [ __ ] to
tom or john charisma whatever the [ __ ]
[ __ ] i was gonna say that great good job
uh dave
and
if if you talk to john charisma that way
when i'm around it makes me
uncomfortable steve windheimer if you
talked to steve wintheimer yeah stephen
pinker okay whatever it is you know who
is it uh he's a making it i don't know
if he's a psychologist or a sociologist
but he's he's famous for okay well go
ahead
he wrote he wrote books uh
better angels what is that what is the
name of that book makko
uh he writes about how the world is in
fact not being becoming a worse place
it's becoming a better safer cleaner
more healthy
uh place than it actually has ever been
consistently year after year decade
after decade century by century making
it up
[Laughter]
better and better and a better place
he's like a [ __ ] professor at harvard
he's like yeah yeah we all are so uh all
right
of our cool
better angels of our nature there we go
that's the worst [ __ ] title i've ever
heard it's not going anywhere it's not a
good testament i couldn't remember it
you know what's even worse that that's
worse than the [ __ ] the commish
remember that [ __ ] title
oh yeah
michael chiklis michael chuck was a
great actor but was in a show called the
commish michael chiklis has been
between the ages of 40 and 45 for 35
years
it's no good dude
from the makers of the lieutenant
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] from a secret branch in the arm
and the knave
[Laughter]
wow i just just finished the goddamn
word [ __ ]
abc or whatever the [ __ ] it was
the commission and we're gonna call it
the commish why not the commissioner
because it's cool
you know what i mean because it's cooler
dude remember when dad made us laugh
about that yeah dude i thought we were
kids and
that's why we thought the title was so
funny because my dad was [ __ ]
laughing so hard that the show's called
the commish dude
and then do you know what the joke was
that made us die
you know when you're laughing really
hard and then somebody says the one
thing that sets you over the edge yeah
and you can't breathe yeah i remember a
time with that for us but go ahead so he
said uh you might as well call it the
vomit oh yeah and and we
[ __ ] died i mean i was like five so
you're rolling in
the vomit
wow that's right
the vomit killed me dude
they called it the vomit
dude that that would be a horror movie
in the 80s the vomit i mean i'd be much
more likely to watch the vomit oh yeah
yeah remember ours the time that we
laughed so hard was and you peed you
actually peed a little bit
because you were laughing so hard you
told me this oh we were on the way back
from utah driving and we were listening
to that song and we were making fun of
the song about how the guy was killing
it in the music yeah we were laughing so
hard and at the end that [ __ ] after
the crescendo of the song it was fading
out and the guy was killing it and he
just goes oh that's [ __ ] right or
whatever dude the song the song he kept
saying every day every day every day and
the very end he goes every [ __ ]
how do you remember that
dude you laughed so hard so did i but
you piss came out i peed yeah bro
the only time i was an adult i've i've
peed my pants yeah
yeah i have diapers that i wear
sometimes in the bed and i try to piss
um that's cause you're lazy though yep
it's not because somebody's making you
laugh i know no i know no i don't laugh
at my sleep like really hard it would be
amazing that'd be great i wish that
would be so good but um and then so i
piss in my diaper and then it it you
can't do depends is [ __ ] honestly
what do you mean it depends
i know what they are but what do you
mean
they're not for heavy peas and i got the
heavy pee ones
that's [ __ ] false advertising that
bro i did a heavy pee when i got up dude
the whole bed was so good
i mean we almost had to get a new
mattress man oh
crystal i was like oh [ __ ] and i was
like i thought they work
40. why didn't you just get up and pee
is what i want to know because i i i
when i get anxious when i go have a lot
of anxiety i have to get up to i realize
it's an anxiety thing i have to get up
to pee in the middle of night too much
and i was like [ __ ] this body i win i
got depends i put them on i'm like i'm
just gonna piss in you and i did and i
[ __ ] it was awful man it was a
travesty yeah i tried it three times
turns out you lose i lose yeah but i
gave it a good [ __ ] college try you
know yeah i don't like that good builder
the good gen good good geriatric try
are there more videos one more yeah
let's do one more okay uh only has one
more let's do only one more only has one
more jake from fort wayne indiana what's
up um i just had a question about
passion so i can't find anything that
i'm really passionate about 30 years old
i have some hobbies you know i like
playing guitar i like playing piano i
taught myself how to tattoo all night i
like reading books walking my dog all
that stuff right guys
but like
i'm not actually passionate about
anything oh wow i just i enjoy doing
them but i'm not like enthralled with
anything do you think that it's okay to
go through life without having a passion
and is it or is it just the fact that
i'm not looking hard enough for it
um thanks so much for doing the podcast
life rips hell yeah life does rip even
if you don't have a passion yet he's
young he's 30 he's still young he's
young did he say he's 30 uh yeah he's
30. he's still young in the modern stuff
he's like as steven picker would point
out the lifespan of the average adult
human is getting longer and longer so
whereas 30 used to be towards the end of
your life a hundred years ago now it's
still even more and more and more at the
beginning of your life so unless that's
steven pinger will point out
uh thank you better
thanks to john charisma um
i think that it's okay
uh to not have a passion yet but i would
start to be concerned about he said is
it okay to live a life without passion i
i don't i don't think that that is
possible to be fulfilled
if you have no passion about anything
for an entire let's say a fully lived
life to like 78 and then you die to be
passionate about nothing would be pretty
extraordinary and i think
not good do you think it will happen
that's what i'm saying though yeah
ultimately i think you will run into
somebody okay don't worry about it but
keep being curious and it sounds like he
is he's reading he's doing [ __ ] he's
exploring himself
doesn't sound like super young but
yeah guys but you don't know until you
try it right you probably not really
really good not with that so um you know
you have a really good idea if you'll
like that before that's what i'm saying
not about that oh yeah um
uh i
okay so i mean this is why people have
kids
yeah yeah i mean this is why people have
kids i don't know how serious you are
with your girlfriend but
that changes but wouldn't you say that
that's the wrong reason to advocate yeah
i would say it's not necessarily the
right reason to have kids but kids can
save you like that i mean like kids can
save your life like that like your
passion yeah danger though danger oh
yeah yeah yeah well well danger to
assume uh i have no passion i'm bored
i'm yeah yeah i guess i should have kids
i i guess what that's saying is there's
a lot of stuff to look forward to you're
still young yes if you want to have a
family there's that there's also other
things like dude nine of the things you
list
[ __ ] seven of the nine of the things
you listed were about music maybe you
just don't like [ __ ] playing musical
instruments you know yeah but i try
other things
find the passion before you have a
family yeah you could but what if you
don't
people's passions are their families
well he's still young i would like to
give yourself another [ __ ] 10 years
get look into mormonism honestly look
into mormonism read the [ __ ] things
of joseph smith the thing pocahontas
read the things of joseph smith and
was not a mormon well whatever yeah no
she definitely wasn't because
you think of john smith yep gotta be
white what'd i say joseph smith joseph
is the mormon guy john smith is the guy
who
oh yes yes joseph smith discovered the
new world
are they with their brothers no what the
[ __ ] were their last name smith
everyone's last name is smith
smith related to them oh is it smith
joseph smith maybe i don't know if he's
mormon or not no he sure could avoid the
[ __ ] team
yeah okay no i don't know is it everyone
is right adam and eve smith
certainly technically everyone is
related there we go and that's what
stephen pinkerton says
john charisma i think that um i think
that yeah passion is coming don't even
worry about it passion is coming you
don't that sounds like a cult leader
right it sounds like yeah game of
thrones don't worry sex passion is
coming you're still young-ish you're 30
but pick up some [ __ ] stuff why don't
you do like a montage in your life why
don't you live your life like a montage
for the next month dude just [ __ ]
just pick up certain things that you're
gonna start doing hacky sack you know
what i mean get a new job for a little
bit just part time go to the park
sunbathe use one of those [ __ ] things
that bounces the [ __ ] rays up into
your face or in your butthole yeah yes
go out into your backyard
uh let the sun receive let the anus
receive your son yeah receive the son
just [ __ ] it
right
mailing [ __ ] he's a mailman
it could be a different kind of montage
can we what i want right you could be it
could be that uh you know [ __ ]
who knows [ __ ] a sailor yeah yeah
what i won't yeah yeah yeah right yeah
we only know
you know what i want be in the [ __ ]
nave be the commish lieutenant be the
lieutenant be in the nave be the commish
be a nayc you know what i mean
um
i uh
i think that you're gonna be okay also
congratulations you're the most regular
looking regular looking man i've ever
seen you've done it you've really done
it you are you're a maximum regular
average
kind of good-looking yeah regular-ass
dude got good really solid brown eyes
though he's did you know he's a good
look he's just the most regular regular
good looking guy yeah congratulations
maybe you don't have passion because of
the way god made you you're just regular
looking right
[ __ ] up your nose a little bit oh yeah
maybe get a tattoo he taught himself had
a tattoo bro if you put your get a neck
tattoo get some trauma in your life
start with like
not so visible and pronounced but get
[ __ ] up like break your nose
uh
[Laughter]
break some bones you know yeah yeah well
that's pretty much all the same thing
all right let's talk about the housing
market wow
30.
uh my wife and i are trying to buy our
first house nice and um
the market's just terrible we moved into
the in-law suite of my parents house
about two years ago
save money for a house and wedding while
we're married now we've got a bunch of
money saved up we're pre-approved for
way more than we should ever spend
but everything on the market is listed
for double what it lasts sold for and uh
we really don't want to do that we
looked at a fixer-upper last night that
it was 215 thousand dollars um and the
realtors probably said we should offer
240 if we want to have a fighting game
so yeah like 240 for fixer-upper is
ridiculous yeah i want to let you want
to see what you guys think
um and this is my work van all right i'm
sure chris has already mentioned it
what the [ __ ] this guy in a coffin so
anyways cool that's what a work van
looks like chris thanks guys yeah i
wouldn't know so uh
yeah dude the [ __ ] housing market is
insane yeah it's really really stupid
it's insane i
it can't be like this for for too much
longer depending no it's it's gonna it's
slowing down right now already it is
very very top of the market is is really
slowing down really really really fast
right and drastically but that that's
the very top of the market yeah not
right that's anyone that we yeah yeah
so and that'll trigger but that's yeah
exactly yeah circle now i i know that
from ronald reagan okay trickle down
economic can you tell you that uh
yeah i don't know something back then
but he um
yeah dude you gotta wait bro you're
you're in a nice spot i know you don't
want to be with the [ __ ] in-law is it
the in-laws or you're you're paranoid
but absolutely oh god okay so too many
[ __ ] releases yeah definitely um
yeah i think i you got to wait you're in
a position now where you can wait i
think you should wait it's just too much
i know you want because here's the other
thing too don't get a fixer-upper and
this is why you don't get a fixer-upper
because you're what do you say is 30 30.
dude
this may not be your dream house and
that's okay this may not be your dream
house and that may be okay because
you'll you can get that you have plenty
of time to do that so right now what you
don't want to do is blow a bunch of cash
that you don't have to when you could
wait another year
and then
[ __ ] blow less cash and then have
more cash for either fixing [ __ ] up or
also your dream house later i wish she
said where he was though yeah i mean
that makes a big difference because
sometimes depending upon the area a
place like sometimes some markets just
actually don't go down
they stagnate and go up slower than
other times like in the last two three
years the la housing market has been
just like straight up going like my
[ __ ] boner like my boner just
straight up nope
or whatever but now when the l.a market
starts to go like this yeah dude like
you're both
it'll be like still up but not as much
so shut the [ __ ] up
um
i hope you do understand so uh they
market like this is like right now like
for me i'm not gonna say it for the
world worst housing expert
housing expert
but depending upon where you are what's
going to happen is we're going to get
down to maths level whereas some markets
just i'm not going to say that actually
might go down at some point and you
don't want to spend
too much money in a place that is never
going to ever reach that level again so
like if he's in a market that is
constantly getting like western beach it
wouldn't matter but if you're in a
market that like who the [ __ ] would
generally in normal times want to buy a
house there and you're spending over
asking that's a [ __ ] bad idea oh so
west palm beach is not what you're
saying because yeah he's always [ __ ]
boner-like so but if he's in west palm
beach then you might want to spend over
because you're never going to really
yeah right because the bonus is not
going to get stronger you're going to
make less money right
shut
up about boners where's john charisma
when you [ __ ] need him dude so um
yeah but he's not he's pro let's assume
he's not in one of those places those
places are not the majority john
charisma no no no no no
[ __ ] new york
la
west palm beach vancouver boner city
probably atlanta to places that are
always growing my boner city
other places match bonuses san francisco
those places are always on the up
me
other like you know okay omaha okay
okay
oh absolutely so bad at breaking it down
for people too so they understand that
oh you're you're a boner okay
acronym this is your bunner on acro okay
okay
look so what's your advice for the guy
um
go to a place
where that's more like your
boner where at the [ __ ] market is
going to be
a little bit more like my boner a little
bit later no go to a place that is going
up up always so that if here's the deal
if you really want to get the [ __ ] out
of there
then go to a place where the market is
never really going to be depressed or
crashed but also if you're in a place
that isn't like that and you're
unwilling to look at a place that is
like that then absolutely wait and wait
till your money can go further can go
longer it can really stretch but you
don't want to get a fixer-upper you
don't you don't want to max out and get
a fixer-upper because where the [ __ ] are
you going to get the money to fix it up
right right right if you're going to go
over and max the [ __ ] out you have to be
getting your dream house already yeah
yeah okay yeah you're right you're right
dude but wait it out a little bit for
the most part because it's crazy right
now everything's on yeah unless you can
get your dream house for the 240 or
whatever yeah good
points point all right cool um all right
well you know that's good look we got uh
congratulations podcast also out there
on the super cult studios and uh we got
the new page going so subscribe and
we're gonna have more shows coming out
so uh
you know we love you thanks for watching
and uh i'm gonna be in grand prairie
texas which is the dallas uh market and
atlanta and uh florida and denver and
all those places so go to chrislea.com
to get tickets
and uh if you have a question sent in a
video the link is in the description
below or go to watchlifeline.com
thank you
hello
[Music]